Ellen is with us and Ellen is in
Illinois starting off this hour
hi Ellen how are you doing how are you
Dave better than I deserve
what's up okay me and my husband we're
54 we just started your baby steps back
in November and we have about as a right
now about $88,000 still the pay on on
baby step 2 I I suffer from a chronic
lung heart lung condition and my
psychologist whom I love dearly entrust
very well ask me point like last week
when I was going to go on disability now
I'm not on IV medication an oxygen yet I
do need to get myself a a handicap
placard now I work as an IT technician
most of my stuff is phone support so I
it just really it really shook me up and
I'm thinking we're still in baby step
two and we have next to no retirement
and we still have over a hundred
thousand dollars left on our house and I
just you know I'm just overwhelmed I
understand so um what do you make and
what does your husband make my husband
makes about eighty-nine thousand and I
make fifty seven thousand before taxes
that's gross okay so let's run out a
worst-case scenario let's just wave a
wand and today poof you are on SSI
government permanent disability by the
way it's not waving a wand it'll take
months maybe aside from the fact that
we're dealing with that but let's just
say you went from fifty-seven thousand
to twenty twenty thousand dollars a year
twenty thousand okay okay
probably probably what it might be 30 I
don't know but somewhere in there
somewhere between there's probably were
USS I will land and doing that you are
also allowed to work a certain amount or
and you could do some IT you know from
home part time on your own schedule
contract wise okay okay
and so you could add another ten
thousand will say if that's what they
allow let's say they allow that okay so
we've got twenty thirty we've really got
thirty or forty thousand dollars worth
of income instead of fifty seven your
husband mentioned your husband makes
ninety so you've got a household income
in excess of a hundred thousand dollars
you're 54 years old I'm not panicking
just I'm just overwhelmed I know but did
you hear the math I just did yes I get
is the way to not be overwhelmed is to
have a plan to eat the elephant you eat
an elephant to bite at a time and you're
overwhelmed because there's an elephant
standing in front of you called $80,000
worth of debt $100,000 mortgage and no
retirement three big things called an
elephant right so what are we gonna do
well we're a family apart from the fact
that you physically are suffering and
hurting with these thing ailments but
apart from that you're a family that
makes in excess of a hundred thousand
dollars and would continue to make in
excess of a hundred thousand dollars in
Illinois and you can pay off debt pay
off your mortgage and build some wealth
I mean you've got ten fifteen years or
more to do that of your husband's
working life left and so you know I
think this is very doable are you gonna
end up worth 10 million dollars oh I
doubt it unless something changes in
this story but they can change but but I
I think you can move towards disability
if that's truly where you are now I your
psychologist is not a medical doctor
neither am i so you need to talk to one
about whether you're disabled or not I
don't know I assume you are based on
what you're saying okay but if you just
run that if you just run that idea to
ground
you say okay I'm gonna start the process
of permanent disability which is going
to involve part-time work and a
disability income from the government in
addition to my husband's $90,000 we're
gonna get on that budget and we're gonna
work through eighty thousand dollars
worth of debt just like we were before
this really doesn't change your equation
but about 20 grand a year oh wow so
you're making you're making fifty seven
if you make thirty on disability and
another ten that's 40 that's seventeen
thousand dollars of difference so if
it's 27 it's still you still are gonna
you're gonna be fine because your
husband has a really good income and you
will still have some income coming in
it's not like you're going from fifty
seven to zero so that's my point I think
if that's the way this is gonna unfold
then you're gonna be fine
oh and by the way it's gonna take a year
to get there so you're gonna make 57
this year one more year in this equation
and you're gonna make that much more
progress in the process so applying for
disability I don't think means you just
have to quit I don't know you need to
check on that find out exactly what the
process is to be declared by your
medical physician disabled not your
psychologist and and then have that done
in such a way that you will be approved
for your government SSI which you know
when you turn 65 you would convert that
just to Social Security at that point
again your husband is going to work from
now until probably 70 most people do
these days and you guys are going to be
just fine these numbers work you're
gonna be okay